welcome to the stream just gonna wait a
couple minutes for people to sign on we
are going to be talking about a pretty
major problem affecting the David Pakman
show right now and I've sort of been
silent about this really for the greater
part I mean with a few very quick
segments a few quick segments on the
show over the last couple of months it's
been pretty quiet I haven't been talking
about this too much partially because I
don't want to just you know bump people
out about what's going on partially
because there's been so much news that
that's mostly what every single show is
concerned with partially because I don't
want to just fill up the show with
negative stuff but we're facing a pretty
significant problem at the David Pakman
show right now and I'm gonna lay it all
out for you saman or just wait a second
for people to kind of come into the live
stream give me about 10 minutes to lay
it all out that's that's really all the
time that I need if this is your first
live stream just as a heads up as people
connect this is really a live stream
unless you're watching a replay right
now it's July 5th 531 p.m. Eastern Time
that's when I'm doing the show live if
the show is live you can use super chat
which is the dollar symbol at the bottom
of the chat window to send questions or
comments and I will answer them or if
it's a comment I'll read it and comment
on your comment that's a feature that is
available during the live stream so
please use super chat the dollar sign at
the bottom of the chat window number
three new members and patrons in other
words if you subscribe to david pakman
show membership or become a patron
during the stream I will give you a live
shout out thank you and sing your
praises during the stream david
pakman.com slash membership for the
former membership and patreon.com slash
david pakman show for the latter the
patreon pledge page please don't troll
lastly obvious trolling and hate will
get you banned i'll ban you if i
see it moderators have been fully
deputized to ban people as they see fit
and by all means use the use the chat to
participate okay but just don't use it
to troll because nobody likes that
alright so here's what's going on I I
first talked about this and I talked
about this pretty extensively at the
very beginning of April and then I've
been talking about it less and less
because it was clear that we had sort of
hit a saturation point with this issue
and I was basically hoping the david
pakman show would be able to come
through this but our youtube channel is
only making about 15% of the revenue
that it was in the first few months of
the year okay and this is a pretty major
deal I wish I could understate the
importance of this but the reality is we
estimate somewhere between half and one
percent of our audience is a sort of
financial contributor to the program
either through membership or patreon and
as a result we were pretty dependent on
YouTube revenue it wasn't the majority
of our revenue the majority of our
revenue has always been direct support
but close to 50% of our revenue some
months it was 40 some months it was 45
was coming from YouTube The Wall Street
Journal put out this alarmist hyperbolic
article in late March with a screenshot
of I believe it was a coca-cola ad in
front of just a obviously racist video
on some tiny channel with 800
subscribers right for comparison we're
closing in on 400 thousand subscribers
so this is effectively an insignificant
channel and brands went crazy saying oh
my god
YouTube can't control when our ads are
showing up we've got to threaten to pull
out so that YouTube will fix this in
turn YouTube's panicked and on March
31st they turned on they basically
flipped the switch on a new ad algorithm
which was so strict that it made
anything we were talking about we were
talking about gay marriage we were
talking
out Trump Russia whatever it was all
flagged as too controversial for ads to
run on it and as you'll see in this
image that I'm putting up by the number
two you will see that our revenue
dropped to effectively nothing like
you'll see that the line the dips are
just above zero but it was effectively
nothing as I told you before we lost
about 99 percent of our revenue okay
compare it to the area by the number 1
which was sort of like the bulk of after
the the early January sort of vacation
period or we would expect revenue to
sort of be down the beginning of a new
year etc we were having a very solid
year record-setting
in fact and down to effectively 0 I
reached out to YouTube I said guys we're
getting crushed here we've got staff
we've got a studio this is part of our
business model it's not half of it but
it's close to half of it do you know
that this is going on and I would get
form letters back from YouTube of no
meaning whatsoever and I push through
and eventually I got a hold of actual
people at YouTube they were shocked at
what happened to our channel I explained
to them this is what's going on we're
making effectively nothing and they said
we're gonna look into it we're gonna try
to help you the people that I know at
YouTube came back to me and they said
David we figured out what's going on the
YouTube algorithm has incorrectly
identified your channel as a purveyor of
not WorkSafe content but you're right
David you don't have profanity your
programme is FCC safe you should be
making money on YouTube and they said
rest assured it's gonna fix itself and
true to their word as you can see after
this area by the number 2 the numbers
started to recover they still weren't
good numbers but in late April in early
May in late May they got back to what I
told you on the program a few times was
roughly about a third of the revenue
that we had been experiencing prior to
these this crisis okay and I said to
myself you know 1/3 is not great but we
can more easily make up 66% of our
revenue than 99% of our revenues so I
thought well we're going in the right
direction and maybe by the end of summer
by early fall if people really pitch in
and become members and become patrons we
might be able to make up that lost
revenue unfortunately the last few days
of June and the first few days of July
have been a total and utter disaster and
at this point the people I know at
YouTube seem to have run out of answers
at this point I believe that this is the
new normal and as you can see a
precipitous decline by the number four
and there is every indication I've
talked to some of the other producers
that are dealing with this in news in
politics this does appear to be the new
normal
YouTube has stopped responding to me
unfortunately there is no indication
that this is going to improve and we we
now are unfortunately in a very serious
situation because we've got major major
plans we've got plans for close to a
dozen long-form videos that we're
working on for you those require a lot
of production time we've got plans for a
12 to 15 part miniseries on critical
thinking and logical fallacies that I
believe if we can get it done is gonna
be one of the best things that the
program ever does we've got major plans
when it comes to public events and
appearances that are gonna involve the
audience if all goes well we have all of
these things planned and unfortunately
now we have lost 85% of our YouTube
revenue YouTube revenue of course making
up previously close to half close to
half of our total revenue so we've got a
couple options right option one is what
we get rid of our staff get rid of the
studio I basically go back to video
blogging which is basically what I'm
doing right now becomes the show this
would have terrible impact
this would have a terrible impact we
distribute the show to 200 radio and
television stations they expect a
certain level of quality if we go to
this which is how I like to talk to you
in a more personal setting but this
isn't the show that's a problem we keep
staff in studio but we shrink the amount
of production that we're doing each week
maybe instead of five shows a week we do
three shows a week we go back to the old
days or something like that
these aren't good options and these are
especially not good options given that
we have an administration right now that
would love to see diversity of voices
reduced that would love to see
adversarial media go away go the way of
the dodo for lack of a better term so
not only do I don't want to do do I not
want to do that because we've been
building this thing for years I don't
want to do that because this is a key
time this is a key time for shows like
ours so what I'm doing instead is I am
basically going to be focusing on the
methods that have already been effective
at providing half of our revenue and
seeing if we can grow that maybe a 70%
of our revenue maybe to 80% of our
revenue and before I tell you what we're
doing this is I can't possibly overstate
the importance of this enough we
estimate that between 1/2 of 1 percent
and 1 percent of our audience currently
contributes financially so there doesn't
need to be some major victory where half
the audience is paying for the show the
whole point of the show is we want it to
be available for free to people right
that's the whole idea
we succeed we crush ad pocalypse as it's
being called if we simply get to 2 and a
half to 3 percent of our audience
supporting us financially that's it so
if you say to me David you know a lot of
people have no money for independent
media that's great don't worry about it
if you can't contribute $1 a month don't
contribute $1 a month
use that money for other stuff my goal
is the show will still be available to
you but if there's 15 percent of our
audience that could afford a doll
a month and half of them or even a
quarter of them decide to contribute a
dollar a month the problem ends and that
is why it's so important not to be
dissuaded from contributing at all if
you can only contribute a dollar or two
so this fortunately for us major
investigative pieces have been written
about what's going on with our YouTube
channel Amanda Hess over at The New York
Times did an awesome job investigating
not only how YouTube has changed their
advertising algorithm but specifically
how it has affected our show you can
read
Amanda's article from a couple months
ago at the New York Times it's called
how YouTube's shifting algorithms hurt
independent media this is a major New
York Times technology article about the
David Pakman show
okay check it out we also had Davey Alba
over at Wired write a great article
called want a better web here's an idea
pay for it we are going to get the forms
of media that we support and it is again
an article about YouTube ad pocalypse
but particularly particularly focused on
the David Pakman show tremendous
absolutely tremendous article check it
out to learn about what it is that is
going on here and there's really no
clearer picture that can be painted then
the picture that's on the screen right
now which is look at number one look at
number two look at number three which
looked like we were starting to go in
the right direction and then look at
number four which is where we find
ourselves today now I'm not going to go
quietly into the night right there is no
way that that is something that I'm
going to do so it's really really
important that people understand that
this is really a this is not a complex
nut to crack
right we mostly depend on funding from
our audience we've got close to 400,000
YouTube subscribers right now
if 1% of you went to patreon.com slash
david pakman show and donated just $1 a
month
1% right not 5% not two and a half
percent if just 1% of you right about
3,700 people went over to patreon.com
slash david pakman show and threw in a
dollar or two per month the problem is
over the problem is over membership if
you go to david pakman.com slash
membership and sign up for a membership
if just one half of 1% of our YouTube
audience were to do that right now we
solve this thing ok so a couple
different things that you can do if you
want to help these are really really
simple and it's just a matter of what
this program is worth to you and you
know what if it's not worth anything to
you
don't contribute right it's super easy
if the program is worth nothing to you
don't contribute if each youtube video
is worth a few pennies to you you go to
david pakman.com slash membership and
you can sign up for $6 a month you can
sign up for $6 per year and if the
normal rates are too high hey I'm not
looking to bankrupt anybody if the
normal rates are too high on the second
page of the signup process there's a
coupon code field you can enter the
coupon code
I voted 17 all one word all lowercase
you will save 40 percent okay that will
make your membership three dollars and
sixty cents a month paid monthly or
three dollars a month pay dearly if you
do that you were talking about under two
cents per youtube video that we create
that's all we're talking about here and
if just one or two percent of you did
that I never have to mention the YouTube
ad boycott again never ever again
patreon if you don't want to deal with
this whole I don't want to create an
account at david pakman.com i don't want
to set up a membership I don't care
about the member benefit some people do
some people don't we do some great stuff
for members but maybe you don't care
about it if you just go to
patreon.com/scishow you can contribute a
dollar a month now if you genuinely
can't afford $1 a month
my mission to you is to continue
producing this show and making it
available to you at no cost that's
always been the goal and that continues
to be my goal but if you can't afford $1
a month and a lot of people can that
dollar a month covers the lost revenue
from two or three viewers on YouTube we
calculated that at full YouTube revenue
if you watched every one of our hundred
and sixty monthly YouTube videos we
would earn about thirty to fifty cents
off of you so if you just contribute a
dollar you're basically making up for
two to three YouTube subscribers okay
we're not talking about anything crazy
so please consider doing those things
let me take a look at some of the super
chats that are here I'm glad to talk
about politics as well in the meantime
though let's you I will send a thank you
and I will thank every single person who
is contributing okay and I'm seeing in
another window here that people are
starting to make contributions thank you
and I will thank every one of you
shortly but let's jump into some of the
super chats okay we had let me see here
I actually had I think I might have
missed a super chat because a number of
them came in let me see if I can pull up
the master list here I don't want to
miss anybody's messages on super chat
okay where do we have that just give me
a second here folks and I will get to it
h:g has sent a $10 super chat saying
nothing other than great show I
appreciate that thank you so much HG Leo
Wiseman has sent a super chat saying
guardian reports progressives are
celebrating the I guess the Affordable
Care Act delay the American Health Care
Act delay is a huge victory premature I
say is there a way to improve health
care policy despite Republicans there is
and I talked about that on the program
today and let me address that again a
little bit later
Jacob ball has sent a $5 super chat
saying first super chat of the day
keep up the good work Dave Dave thank
you very much I appreciate that
and we are going to do everything we can
to continue the program unfettered
Jennifer crane has sent the $20 super
chat other than patreon and membership
how can we help can you run a contest or
perhaps a raffle
so Jennifer by the way we announced on
the program today has sponsored for free
david pakman show membership the theme
of those free memberships is progressive
patriotism there will be a standalone
YouTube clip about that a little bit
later today okay so so Jennifer you're
doing a lot but great question listen
the most direct ways to help our patreon
and membership if you're already a
patron and a member you can do what
Jennifer did which is to get in touch
and say hey I would like to cover 50% of
ten memberships figure out a way to
raffle them off or to give them away or
I'd like to donate five memberships or
something like that which has a two-fold
impact it brings in revenue for the show
and it also brings in new people that
might not be able to afford a membership
and sometimes those folks when they get
a membership for free become real
evangelists for independent media and
for the show so those are a few ideas
you can also get your David Pakman show
stickers apparel and coffee or as some
people are calling it david pakman show
cap feffy at david pakman.com slash gear
i actually tried to make cobb feffy from
our espresso blend which we have at
david pakman.com slash gear and it went
okay I mean I think it needed a lot of
[ __ ] more sugar than than a normal
coffee application but it was it was
okay
Kyle Waller has sent a $5 super chat
saying much love David Pakman okay well
that's yeah there you go thank you so
much Kyle very very much appreciate it
and on that note let me get to some
thank yous okay I want to get before I
even do the thank-yous if we get to 2000
patreon patrons I will do an entire
broadcast show from our studio with my
hair like this okay say what they will
at our affiliate stations radio and
television
stations which broadcast the show every
day if we get to 2,000 patrons I will do
an entire show with my hair like this
and on that note we have a number of new
patrons at patreon.com slash david
pakman show that I want to thank right
now Aurora Clausen has just pledged $5 a
month
Robin harley has increased their pledge
from two to five dollars a month
Nate Hanes has pledged two dollars a
month
Rebecca Warren has pledged two dollars a
month josh Hulbert has pledged two
dollars a month
Barbara Ferguson has pledged five
dollars a month Sara Eddington has
pledged five dollars a month thank you
to all of you we are well we have a
strong start today on this live stream
with the patreon pledges by all means I
am glad to read names all night so keep
the pledges coming on the membership
side which of course you can sign up for
at david pakman.com slash membership if
you want a 40% discount and you don't
have to accept that discount but if you
want that discount you can use the
coupon code
I voted 17 okay that will save you 40%
off of membership and I've got a number
of new members to thank right now Hector
Velasco has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership opting for a
level 2 membership with no coupon code
thank you very much I appreciate that
Matt Cunningham has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership alex pannier
co has signed up on our website Michael
Muldoon has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership membership
Matthew Cunningham has become a member
Stephanie dick has signed up Daniel
Harvey is now a member Damon wreath has
become a member Chris Gonzalez is now a
member thank you thank you so much
because that this is this is not a good
time for
and what the the last option okay what I
would call the nuclear option is
reducing the amount of programming that
we produce that is the last thing that I
want to do and we will do everything we
can you have my promise
to avoid that as an outcome okay let's
dip back into the Super chats a lot of
people asking questions here Christina
asks with a $2 Super chat do you keep
all of the super chat money or only a
percentage listen I don't actually know
the answer to that at one point I read
that we kept only half of Super chat
revenue and then I looked at the numbers
of the day after a super chat and it was
clear that no that's not the case we
keep way more than that and then another
day I looked at it and it looked like we
basically kept all of the super chat
revenue I don't know exactly how much
YouTube takes at this point but it seems
to be a relatively modest amount math
you could tell sent a $5 Super chat
saying keep up the quality work we need
something to balance out the propaganda
on pho news that's my goal Matthew
that's why we're here
a kind cents a 20 Danish kroner super
chat saying please fix the lack of
treble on your non live videos yeah I
think that you commented about the audio
last time a kind and we looked into it
and checked with our affiliates and
checked with a bunch of people nobody
else had any complaints about the lack
of treble it seemed to be sounding
pretty good and we weren't able to
identify the issue so I apologize about
that gr the infamous gr so this month
we've got Jennifer karein who has
donated four memberships and we will be
giving them out through something that
we're gonna call the progressive
Patriots patriotism contest and there
will be more about that on our youtube
channel later last month gr the
patriarch of the incoherent rants on
super chat donated six memberships and
we gave those out last month so between
last month and this month we've had two
existing members and contributors
contribute ten memberships for people
who
could could otherwise not afford them
and that's a really really great thing
gr chiming in today with a $2.00 super
chat the dzb my free speak Creed decree
tree right right thank you I think that
that's a compliment I'm not totally sure
but I believe that that absolutely is a
compliment okay I want to tell you about
the long-form investigative pieces that
we have coming up on the show if this is
a feature of our program that you're not
yet familiar with let me point you to a
couple of different things number one if
you go to our main youtube channel
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
we have added a new playlist called
deeper dives okay this is a compilation
playlist of our longer form videos which
range from as short as 11 minutes all
the way up to half-hour videos these
started with the infamous reza aslan
cannot be trusted video back in January
of 2016 which was researched by david
former david pakman show in turn now
producer noah ferguson some of the other
long-form deeper dives that are
available on our youtube channel
the truth about political correctness
the truth about the alt-right the truth
about donald trump the truth about
police shooting black men the truth
about the regressive left the truth
about the gender pay gap the truth about
dangerous job stealing immigrants
anti-vaxxers have been around as long as
vaccines have safe spaces replaced free
spaces at universities it goes on and on
and on these are different videos than
the three to eight minute topical things
we do on the show okay we have a very
long list a very long list of other
long-form videos on our production
agenda and this is why the YouTube ad
boycott really worries me because it
takes a lot of time to produce these
videos it usually is a couple weeks
research narration is done it could take
a week for video editing it is an
iterative process that is very a staff
time intensive okay here are some of the
ideas that we're working on for these
long-form videos and I don't want to not
be able to do these videos because of
the YouTube ad pocalypse classical
liberalism is pretty [ __ ]
conservative okay that is the sort of
idea possible title for one of the
long-form videos that we're working on
and that will relate directly to this
trend of people saying they are their
classical liberals now okay we're gonna
talk about that in detail we are
thinking of these are possibilities race
and IQ okay and this is going to include
the recent controversy involving sam
harris and charles murray on sam
Harris's podcast this is going to really
be a deep dive into race and IQ we're
thinking about doing a video on cultural
Marxism not a hundred percent yet but we
might okay we're gonna we're gonna think
about that we're going to maybe in
relation to actually today's segment on
the show about patriot of progressive
patriotism we're thinking about doing a
video a long-form video about the
concepts of patriotism nationalism and a
better type of patriotism okay socialism
has never worked socialism has never
worked as a popular refrain from many
and that is a topic ripe for a deep dive
the use of data analytics in both voter
targeting and voter suppression these
are many of these have been suggested by
you that is another possibility social
conservatives have been on the wrong
side of history for a very long time
okay that's another idea for a long long
form video and then we've got that
others some people want me to look into
Jill Stein and Russia I'm open to that
many people want to expand our
conversations about universal basic
income into a broader video and deep
dive into post work ISM okay there's a
lot of ideas here I want to do every
single one of these and something else
that we have going
which I think would be arguably one of
the best things that the show will ever
have done okay is we have a 90 percent
completed 12 to 15 part miniseries on
critical thinking okay people write to
me David a lot of school districts don't
teach critical thinking anymore people
are showing up to college not even
knowledgeable about basic critical
thinking and epistemology you should do
a video or a series about critical
thinking I have written in collaboration
with former producer Rachel Gordon a
multi-part series on critical thinking
which we are now starting to look at
with producers Pat and Noah into how we
can finish that last 10% and then figure
out how to turn this into a 12 to 15
part miniseries on critical thinking we
need that right now I I can't think of a
time actually where we needed it more
it's very time intensive it is very time
intensive and I look forward to
completing that for you sooner than
later
and these are all the types of projects
that I don't want to see affected by
this which is the precipitous decline in
our YouTube ad revenue over the last few
months and particularly acutely over the
last 10 to 15 days to what appears to be
appears to be the new normal so a lot of
you with peace and love are trying to
mitigate this problem some of you via
patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a contribution
of as much as you want but you can make
a contribution for as little as $1 per
month and many of you have done exactly
that Joe Allen has just pledged two
dollars per month via patreon if you
can't afford to do one most of you can
afford $1 a month and if you can't I'm
not asking you for the donation I'm
producing the show for you
and that's why it's so important we keep
the show going Andrew and Joe last row
has just pledged two dollars a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
thank you thank you so much I really
appreciate that and then on the
membership side on the membership side
and members get sometimes there's
confusion like what David what do you do
membership what on earth are you talking
about membership has been around since
2010 it's the number one funding source
for the program and we actually have
currently a 40% discount code which is
available to you I'll tell you about
that in a second and I've got some major
major thank yous to to give cliff
Throckmorton has just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership as has gary
atkins and chris linenger thanks to the
three of you for signing up some of them
have used the coupon code
I voted 17 and the way to use that I see
some comments in the chat some confusion
about how to use that code you're seeing
page one of the signup process which is
david pakman.com slash membership once
you select your membership either
monthly or yearly and click the red sign
up button you will be taken to page two
of the signup process and that's where
you can enter the coupon code which is I
voted 17 all one word all lowercase and
this is a very simple and
straightforward process and you do get
as a member the daily bonus show we do
an extra show many people don't know
this so I've heard that we do an entire
extra show every day just for our paid
subscribers and we talk about different
types of stories sometimes they are well
I mean they're just different stories
than than would be on the regular show
and it's absolutely tremendous and
there's lots of other great member
benefits as well so please keep those
coming and I will absolutely keep the
thank-yous going okay let's jump back
into the Super chats here Stan Estelle
Bose has sent a 10 euro super
with no question or comment thank you
very much Hobbiton has sent the five
British pound super chat can I use super
chat to get you to say nonsense like
wacky waving inflatable arm-flailing
tube-man or is that unwanted trolling
well but I think my answer speaks for
itself
Tina Howard has sent a $2.00 super chat
Tina thank you very much
Jacob ball has sent the $20 super chat
would you ever consider doing a deep
dive into campaign finance I'd like to
see a history of how we got to where we
are now and a general breakdown of what
percentage of the time congressmen vote
in ways that benefit their donors very
very good topic and I'm gonna bookmark
it and add it to our list because that
is that would be a very very good topic
Klaus m54 has sent a 2 euro super chat
Europe cares about progressive voices in
the u.s. Thank You Klaus I really
appreciate that
Tina Howard has sent a $5 super cheque
no question or comment thank you very
much game fire 74 has sent a $5 ninety
seven cents super chat why do you not
talk about identity politics why do
people say that isn't useful you
mentioned that to a caller last week
well I I do talk about identity politics
and we've talked in fact I think more
than a lot of other programs about
identity politics and I am not someone
who believes that the recent paradigm of
sort of intersectionality and identity
politics as a primary sort of platform
point has been good for the progressive
movement in fact I think it's been the
opposite I think it's important to
distinguish between the type of identity
politics that recognizes that there are
individuals whose identity is
disproportionately a factor in
subjugation or discrimination right a
bit by saying I don't think identity
politics is necessarily useful I'm not
saying
there is not discrimination in this
country based on identity I think it's
really important to point that out but
the point is that the way in which
identity politics has been carried out
in great part by the left over the last
you know few years has not been useful
to the progressive movement nor to the
Democratic Party so it's it's a nuanced
issue and it probably is actually one
that that maybe warrants a deeper dive
as well so I'm gonna make a note about
that identity politics and then we had
the campaign finance idea as well all
good ideas very very important ideas
next super chat is from Mario Sonic
zooni I'm not exactly sure how it's
pronounced a 2 euro super chat and I
very very much appreciate that Andres
Sanchez has asked with a 2 dollar super
chat what benefits you more signing up
for membership or patreon it's pretty
similar I mean the the amount that is
taken by the payment processor is now
almost identical on both so it's really
a matter of where where would you
contribute more if you're looking at
contributing $5 a month it's basically
the same whether you do it via patreon
or membership for us ok
Bala five nine eight four has sent a 2
euro super chat will abri de gray come
back he's interesting listen I let me
make a note of it Aubrey de Grey
interview we've had aburrida grey is one
of the lead researchers into solving the
problem of aging and that's his language
not mine
that's how he sees it and and what he
talks about and he has been a guest on
the program a number of times and I
would love to have him back on it's been
a while since he's been on and I think
that that would be that that's a really
great idea thank you for suggesting it
and I will reach out to him we will we
will try to get him back on I think he's
actually and it's funny when we have
Aubrey de Grey on and this guy's been
feet he's quite well known he's been
featured everywhere from 60 minutes to I
don't even know where else I mean just
all over the map he
he's been been featured and interviewed
I get people who believe abri degre is
an incredible genius and they find the
interview endlessly riveting and then
there are others who say this guy's
living in a fantasy world nothing he's
working on will ever lead to any actual
increases in life expectancy or
something like that and it's you know
you can't please everybody but I find
Aubrey de Grey very very interesting
endlessly interesting ok I'm seeing some
people in the in the chat say that
something was up with my audio for some
period of time saying that I was
completely inaudible for a full minute
can people confirm that I mean that
seems like a major technical issue if I
was inaudible for an entire minute
during the stream anybody in the chat
want to confirm or deny that I was not
audible for a minute because everything
is properly connected
I believe we're experiencing correct
modulation and and I'm seeing the audio
bar move up as I talk so I would be a
shock to me let me put it that way if I
was totally inaudible for an entire
minute audio is perfect one commenter
says mmm
there was an issue with the stream but
it faked it's fixed itself no for a bit
you dropped for 5 seconds you froze
couple of seconds audios good video is
frozen it stopped and buffered for 5
seconds I could hear you no problem ok
all right well it seems like it might
have been an isolated issue
Tina Howard has sent a $2.00 super chat
thank you Kevin Wilson has sent a 2
British Pound super chat how is Louis
doing ok Louis of course former David
Pakman show producer he has been gone
nearly a year at this point I guess just
under 10 just over 10 months a former
producer Louis has been gone he is doing
fine he still has not moved to the south
he has moved out of Boston he is working
at a brewery and
is not what's the way to say it he is
not committed to any particular path
forward in life I guess is what I'm
trying to say and I saw him over the
weekend we went to lunch on when was it
we went to lunch on Monday on July 3rd
we are both going to be at the same
wedding in a couple of weeks and then
we're going to be in the same wedding
down in Arizona in a couple of months so
yeah Luis seems to be doing ok cata lot
sent a $5 super chat thank you David
from Laurie Bishop Thank You Laurie
appreciated light arrow has sent the
five euro super chat push Perry has sent
the ten dollar super chat saying have a
good day David well thank you and the
day it is improving thanks to many of
you activating because I mean the reason
for this livestream was to tell you
about the disaster that we are currently
experiencing on YouTube because of the
YouTube advertiser boycott our YouTube
ad revenue is down 85% 85% which is
crippling I mean there's really no other
way to say it and as you see the number
one sort of an estimate of YouTube ad
revenue at the beginning of the year
number two was the 99 percent decline
that took place during April it looked
like things were starting to recover
that's number three and number four is
where we have been for the last 10 or so
days and it is bad bad bad and I told
you about that in detail at the
beginning of this stream a number of
articles written about this issue a
great article in Wired about what's
going on with the David Pakman show
YouTube channel a great article in The
New York Times about what's going on
with the YouTube channel and as I
mentioned earlier if and when we get to
2,000 2,000 patrons at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I have committed to
doing an entire broadcast show for our
200 radio and television stations with
my hair like this okay
and along those lines pledges of as
little as a dollar a month are welcome
at
try and calm slash david pakman show we
have new pledges from Peter Slattery who
just in the last 10 minutes has pledged
$2.00 per month and Andres Sanchez who
has pledged $2.00 per month just a few
minutes ago thanks to both of you I
really do appreciate it and I will keep
the thank he was going on the membership
side and of course members at david
pakman.com slash membership get instant
access to a Members Only commercial free
audio or video stream of the show if you
prefer to listen we've got that if you
prefer to watch we've got that for you
as well as instant access to the
world-famous bonus show a daily extra
show produced solely for our paid
subscribers we've got a number of new
members including Bill Harker Emily Carr
and Mario Carr kotero
all of whom have signed up just now at
david pakman.com slash membership and I
could not I could not be more grateful
and of course the various ways to
support us membership at david
pakman.com slash membership patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
if you ever shop on amazon everything
you buy can send us a little kickback if
you go to david pakman.com slash amazon
before you shop i'm gonna get back to
the super chat in a second real quickly
though people have been asking me what
would I like to see be the ultimate
result of the YouTube ad boycott my my
dream would be that member and patrons
support grows so drastically to prevent
this from becoming a crisis for us that
in six months we laugh about this and
say hey you know what we recovered all
the revenue and we don't even need you
to youtube that would really be that's
the sort of dream right that would be
the ideal scenario and every single
patreon contribution and new member gets
us one step closer to that okay let's
see here but
Herbert Holmes has sent a twenty dollar
super chat saying ignorance is intrinsic
how large of a role do you think the
stigma of ignorance in our society plays
in shaping behavior as well as the role
the ego plays well so I actually talked
about this a little bit on the program
today and I hope Herbert that I'm sort
of approaching this from the angle that
that you you were hoping for
there is thick there is some stigma to
ignorance and at the same time you also
have anti intellectualism and we've seen
anti-intellectualism grow but there's an
equally or even more dangerous
phenomenon that's taking place right now
which is pseudo intellectualism and I
say more dangerous because you've got
some people who say hey liberal college
is liberal indoctrination it's nonsense
deep knowledge through reading academic
textbooks is a waste of time
that's anti intellectualism and some
people say I reject that it's good to
know things the problem is that the
right has this in it's like a cottage
industry of pseudo intellectual ISM and
this leads to people who read mark
Levins books and think that they're
informed deeply about issues people who
read Laura Ingram's books as I talked
about today on the broadcast program and
believe that they are informed and when
I say pseudo-intellectual ISM these are
individuals who believe that they have
knowledge about things without realizing
that those whom they are quote learning
from are are basically just partisan
hacks right and that is that is as or
more dangerous than both anti
intellectualism and and the stigma of
ignorance which can sometimes get people
to get engaged and learn about things
simple and complicated things as our
president would say but at the same time
can can get people to separate
completely from anything that would
we would consider sort of like academic
learning so I believe that yes
ignorance and society shapes behavior it
shapes elections it shapes humans
the the the perspective of humanity on
whether an issue is an important issue
to solve or not the climate science
debate is a great example
ignorance there has real impact and we
are going to be talking about that in
quite a bit of detail and in fact anti
and making a note of this pseudo
intellectual ism could be a great topic
for a deep dive a long-form video so
I'll make a note of that
game fire 74 has sent the $6 and 71 cent
super chat asking being in Boston how do
you feel about Tom Brady and Donald
Trump being friends I think I recall you
and Pat mentioned being Patriots fans
yeah listen you know it first of all I
don't know what the politics are of Tom
Brady I know that you know he had this
make America great again hat in his
Patriots locker room and giselle the
wife of Tom Brady the Patriots
quarterback said you know the idea that
we're both big Trump supporters
politically is nonsense of course it may
be Tom Brady is a supporter and giselle
is not who knows I don't know I don't
really care about Trump being friends
with Tom Brady Trump at one point was
friends with Howard Stern who I think is
one of the top radio broadcasters and
interviewers and in the history of radio
I don't really care about that per se
what I what I don't like though is when
you see Trump sort of claim support from
people he's friends with even if they
have not actually expressed it and we
saw that done with a bunch of people
during the campaign and that I think is
pretty pretty damn low boxy Brown has
sent a $2 super chat saying do a video
on how jimmy dore is absolute cancer
honestly i don't know a thing about it I
don't I don't know what he is doing on
his show I every once in a while I got
an email from someone who either loves
Jimmy door and hates me because I'm not
like Jimmy door or hates Jimmy door and
praises
me because I'm not like Jimmy Dore but I
couldn't tell you what it is that Jimmy
door is doing
Mario SUNYAC sunic sonic okay I know I'm
badgering it has sent the five euro
super chat could do a comparison of the
US versus the EU generally political
system economy education health care
looking outside the box might help the
US see itself I like that idea
I will make a note of that octopus
translation module has sent the five
dollar super chat love your show band
watching since I was in eighth grade any
chance you'll bring noam chomsky on I'd
love to have Noam Chomsky and he has
previously not responded to our requests
for an interview Matt fern has sent a to
British Pound super chat thank you very
much
gr the king of incoherent rants has sent
the $2 super check my girlfriend Holly
says you're handsome love gr will thank
you and you know I hope gr that that you
don't that you don't hold that against
me geez Courtney Haynes has sent a five
dollar super chat proud five dollar
patreon love patron love the idea of a
critical thinking series
this may sound current corny but
encouraging critical thinking is a cause
that is close to my heart
Michael firster has sent a five Swiss
franc I believe CHF is Swiss franc super
chat don't give up David you were
watched from Switzerland too because we
care about the US thank you I love
Switzerland I have been to Lugano and
Zurich and where else have I been in
Switzerland I guess that's it totally
different love them both insanely
expensive stepped out of my hotel and
saw a place advertising a $32 I'm sorry
a twenty eight Swiss franc which at the
time was roughly $32 cheeseburger and I
said to my girlfriend
we must happen to be across from like
the gourmet top of the top cheese burger
joint in Zurich and she said no it's
what things cost
beautiful country absolutely amazing
Kyle Waller sent a $5 super chat did you
hear about the VidCon incident with
sargon of akkad
and Anita sarkeesian you know I heard
that
Sargon Karl Karl Benjamin went to a
panel at VidCon and Anita sarkeesian was
on the panel and she spotted him and
started I guess like criticizing him
either directly or indirectly or calling
him a harasser of women or something
like that I don't have too many thoughts
about it but if it's if it is as Sargon
described it it sounds bonkers I mean
it's it's it sounds quite quite unhinged
I think that's sort of the the only way
I can put it okay we have been talking
about the implosion of YouTube ad
revenue for the David Pakman show due to
what is called the ad pocalypse you will
see that we have gone from point one
earlier this year in YouTube partner ad
revenue to point four a roughly 85
percent loss in ad revenue a number of
major articles have been written about
this Amanda Hess wrote an article about
what's going on with our YouTube channel
in the New York Times Devi Alba wrote an
article about what's going on with our
YouTube channel in Wired and I could not
thank them enough for it and as a result
we are talking about making up the lost
revenue through membership and patreon
and I don't want to have to change what
or how much content we are producing in
fact you know it's the sick irony it not
irony I don't even know what to call it
the sad nature of this is that we've got
a list of like a dozen long-form videos
and a 12 to 15 part critical thinking
miniseries that we want to do for you
guys this year and we now need to spend
time trying to just make up lost revenue
and we're doing that a few different
ways
membership patreon and Amazon okay let
me do live thank yous because every
single person who contributes deserves a
thank you for doing really really great
things David Hoffman has just pledged
$2.00 a month
two dollars a month makes a big
difference might not sound like a lot
but it makes a big difference even a
dollar a month makes a big difference
cyber Li has just pledged five dollars a
month at patreon.com slash David Pakman
show Gary
Atkins has just pledged two dollars a
month at patreon.com slash David Pakman
show
Vladimir Alexandrov has just paid a
pledged five dollars a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
frui snura snorrison I think I butchered
that has pledged two dollars per month
at patreon.com slash David Pakman show
however patreon is not the only way to
support the show you can get the
commercial-free all-access pass as well
as the bonus show as a member at david
pakman.com slash membership if you want
to save 40 percent off of your
membership you can use the coupon code I
voted 17 all one word all lowercase
which by the way is going to be retired
the coupon code is going to be retired
soon so if you want to take advantage of
it I advise you to do that sooner than
later
and on that note Kristina Dittmar has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership Resha
demenna has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and James
Holcomb has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership thanks to
each and every one of you this is not a
good situation but hopefully with your
help we will be able to weather it and
every single contribution is huge and
and and I appreciate everybody who's
contributed so far gr has sent the $5
super chat know DZ hard feelings are for
sorry men flip flops are for sorry men
like hard feelings
you're handsome I have no more rants son
not today
alright and there is no better note on
which to wrap up this livestream than
that I will thank everybody who
continues to sign up at patreon and men
for membership after the stream ends
believe me folks everybody will get the
thank yous I will live stream again soon